good morning Hank it's Tuesday and today
I'm going to answer Willie's questions
about the American health care reform
bill well to start will you just explain
what the health care reform bill is yeah
but that's harder to do than you would
think because there are actually two
health care reform bills one that passed
the House of Representatives in one that
passed the Senate for our purposes I'm
mostly going to talk about the Senate
bill basically the bill regulates the
insurance industry preventing it for
instance from not insuring people who
have pre-existing conditions and it
creates a private based nonprofit
insurance exchange where people who
don't have jobs or work for themselves
or work for small businesses can go and
get health insurance which will be
subsidized by the federal government
okay but what if I have insurance
through my job you don't have a job
you're a puppy but if you had a job
nothing would change
except arguably your premiums but more
on that in a moment how many people is
this new health bill going to cover
about thirty million Americans who are
currently either uninsured or
underinsured would be covered under this
bill what about pre-existing conditions
under the Senate bill by 2014 health
insurance companies will no longer be
able to exclude people with pre-existing
conditions or charge higher premiums
based on gender because as a rule ladies
are more expensive to insure them dudes
because ladies like I don't know if you
guys know about this this is crazy
but they have babies come out of their
bodies and that is expensive also
wowsie so because insurance companies
won't be able to charge women and people
with pre-existing conditions more it's
possible that the premiums for healthy
relatively young men like myself might
go up but it's possible that will be
offset by the overall decrease in health
care cost that comes from this federally
subsidized insurance pool what's always
talked about funding abortions with
federal money no federal money will go
to funding abortions but the exact
mechanics of this are complicated enough
that I can't explain them in the video
and must explain them in the sidebar so
go down there and read it will this bill
allow illegal immigrants to have access
to health care in the United States well
Willy I don't know if you should be
asking that since you're a Scottish west
highland terrier don't tell the
government but my puppy is a Scotsman
but the answer is that illegal
immigrants already get health care in
America because as a rule emergency
rooms don't turn people away
how will this affect kids and what
happens to me when I turn 18 because
more adults who are uninsured will have
access to health insurance more children
who are uninsured will have access to
health insurance too the bill will also
likely increase the age to which you can
stay on your parents health care to
somewhere in the neighborhood of 20
but does the bill increase taxes yes it
will likely increase the Medicare tax
point nine percent on income over
$200,000 per year which means if you
make three hundred thousand dollars per
year you'll pay about an extra thousand
dollars in tax it also dramatically
increases the tax rate on so-called
Cadillac health insurance plans which
most healthcare analysts think is a good
idea because it will lower the overall
amount of the gross domestic product
that we spend on health care so also
there's going to be a tax on indoor
tanning you're kidding no I'm serious
and actually it's a really good idea
because people who tan indoors have a
much higher chance of getting melanoma
which is a very expensive disease
particularly if you get it young that's
also why we tax cigarettes what's all
this going to do to the national debt
well according to the nonpartisan
Congressional Budget Office it's going
to cut the national deficit but whether
that leads in turn to a cut in the
national debt is largely dependent on
whether we spend that money on something
else like maybe right before the 2010
election Congress will vote to send
every American a lollipop did Nebraska
senator Ben Nelson sell his vote yes he
did that's why he's wearing the ass hat
so under this bill if you're eligible
for insurance do you have to get
insurance yes or I'll to pay a penalty
which will eventually be $750 per person
per year
wait the government is making me get
insurance what about my freedom yeah I
can understand why you're squeamish but
most experts think it just won't work
any other way it's the same reason car
insurance is mandatory the problem is
that your stupid choices affect other
people including people I really care
about like me like if we get in a car
accident you don't just mess up your car
you also mess up my car similarly if you
don't have health insurance you'll be
less likely to seek preventive care and
more likely to have higher overall
lifetime health costs which costs you
might not pay because you might die or
go bankrupt forcing the hospital to pass
along the cost of your care to me and
300 million other people but mostly me
so Hank that the Senate health care bill
is best I understand it if you have more
questions about the health care bill
I'll try to answer them in comments not
in my pants even though I'm pointing to
my pants Willie says best wishes